today's episode is brought to you by
America's best unlimited network don't
miss a show with unlimited data from
t-mobile hello everybody it's time to
take our faith Oh beautiful we all did
it sink trailer we're gonna be talking
about it watching it with you here live
on Australia commentaries Joestar I'm so
excited to talk about face off it's
movies bunkers Spencer J Gilbert yeah
same face off the rock on air pick one
the rock Conair the rock for the Navy
SEAL showdown it gives it the slight
edge huh con hair interesting I go the
rock mm-hmm fight we've all spilled the
same blood in the same mud general it
was a good error though for Nicolas Cage
though it was a one-two-three punch that
was just damn yeah he's here to find a
lot of my movie dumb I still I miss
those types of movies and don't make
them like they used to they really don't
really Michael Bay literally does not
make movies like you know ya know yeah
the last insanely premise to action
movie I've seen that wasn't part of a
franchise I think like John wick is sort
of now I feel like the version it's not
the same at all but it's like that's the
action it's dillings grounded real it's
not like they tried to like cry me
cranked I guess you could argue yes
crank to keep it electrocuting himself
yeah but that was almost even a little
too Winky about how over-the-top it was
like face off just played it totally
straight ball to space on Nicolas Cage's
body what what do you want it's a
cat-and-mouse game where the hunter
becomes the hunted
there's also a fun second tier under
like that cuz there's the standouts
which I think we just named all three
but then there's like the second tier of
96 and 97 of like Broken Arrow and also
John Travolta yeah also Joe was just he
went rogue cuz he was fine the nuke
ground right yeah just was like okay I'm
a traitor it's like a new country the
one I remember now that I love executive
decision
it's a good where Russell 96 never seen
that one that's a good what I've find it
on $5 bin and watch it it's a good
little entertaining action fun that
action movie is one combination of
diehards true diehard the final diehard
was its die hard on a plane and also
he's the president is a different strain
but it's the the mid to late 90s are
like one last burst of action movies
before they all just before they all had
to happen I mean not to get depressing
but yeah it was September 11 sort of
then I feel like stopped the action yeah
the matrix kind of redefined it and then
everyone's just like no we're going
trippy action crazy sci-fi mind-meld e
action and then you lost the man's
bodyguard was kind of a throwback to
that still but like 2001 the terrorist
movie stopped for a very long there were
you couldn't have the big bad guy who
was the Croatian terrorist whatever
picture Europe let it became at well not
until taken but then it was it was the
Bourne franchise never liked the CIA and
exactly yeah it was the Koreans fast hit
man's bodyguard was a little bit of a
throwback to that Oh back yeah I I had
fun with those dumb fun it was like I
had fun with those identically like
those movies yeah and I understand that
they're terrible you don't have to tell
me for some reason
bad for fast and furious yes yes they
are borderline racist yes they are
terribly right with you so this movie is
20 years old 20 years old 20 years old
that was our weird justification for it
yeah we just wanted to do one and we
realized what came out in 1987 hey sighs
we were also debating between Fifth
Element I feel like at one point and
then face saw just the way the releases
happened and with our Emmys last week
thing with face off just happen to still
be on the board and we also like let's
do a good reason to rewatch face off
super fun to rewatch a lot of fun things
about this movie fall through the cracks
we haven't seen in a while because it's
more
just two men who trade faces like weird
love triangles and like just his just
the minutiae of like what's in his
little like swag bag that they keep
giving him last like pills guns for
doobies um dude like for doobies and
there's just so many interesting little
things that you notice on the second
time right and then other things that
are clearly a holdover from when they
started as a sci-fi script like the
prison that they magnetic detract
presume movement which then as we said
it was originally a Stallone in
Schwarzenegger movie which they then
explored more an escape plan which was a
sci-fi prison movie so we just take a
pause because we'll watch the movie in a
second in that video but how cool would
that have been if they've done this with
Schwarzenegger and Stallone like a
different movie but I don't watch that
not sure if they're different enough I
mean I guess they are right yeah it
would have been annotation am I crazy
would you have liked that I stole this
person eager had done it John do I don't
think would have directed it and I think
it would have been funny or like they
would have written it like it could have
been Expendables before we got
Expendables with like Winkie yeah
exactly what I would JT I don't think it
would have been the same movie but
definitely would have been the same it
was very curious to watch it in
researching there was another casting
choice that was Bruce Willis and Alec
Baldwin they're also not at all like
each other yeah DotA stretched the like
same bodies thing a little yeah no weird
rad and I think they would have both
been too serious in a way yeah there's
just there's just lightning in a bottle
of 1997 Nicolas Cage and John Travolta
that weirdly for whatever reason those
two guys were the dudes and yeah you had
to do with them yes I think even more so
than Stallone Schwarzenegger at that
point
sure early 90s was their error and then
it started started tapering away 97 this
movie was exists in the great Hadron
particle collider of Hollywood that it
exists in the only instant it could
exist and yes any other incidents just
be and
there was a stupid but you can love we
love it for it yeah yeah this here Sean
Bean is Boromir being like there was a
dream that was face off instant was gone
yeah no I think I just I never tried to
do face off to another face off right
because you don't know faces I mean look
Nic Cage at the end castor Troy has a
spear through his heart or what
somewhere around there and he is dying
but you got to wonder John Travolta gets
his face back right at the end yeah what
did they do with the other face the
other films and who could have just
clean could have taken that face
Margaret you can add a three swamp yes
someone playing Nicolas Cage has just
his face and his body he's actually
still dead yeah and then you had a new
person the mix would have been fun what
if they freeze the face and his son
grows up this is the third party mix
Alastair tell us in the comments seven
actor for now I guess could be now 2017
actor Malkovich you're both older
interesting we should probably go the
video we're supposed to shut up during
it but yeah what is it just put in the
comments 643 starts here whatever watch
the trailer me that's a good one
watch the trailer this is pretty watch
as well yeah
for better or worse you know their faces
the two of them switch you know they're
gonna get holy orgasms twice Sandro's
fun yep
mutts are cool one cop will do whatever
it takes to take down the man who killed
his son by cutting his rivals face off
and putting that face on his own face
doing absolutely nothing to change his
body feeling instantly from this massive
surgery telling no one what he did and
going undercover in a prisoner's lair
everyone wears high and maybe porking
his rivals girlfriend
all the while hoping his rival doesn't
wake from a coma put his face on his
body's more kismet in his face kill his
boss and challenge him to a deadly
speedboat fight forcing him to harp it
all makes perfect sense if you're on a
lot of cocaine and they have been
involved prepare for the magic you
didn't know you were waiting for John
Travolta versus Nicolas Cage to
oscar-worthy actors who turned into
jokes made the economic um oscar-worthy
again then realize it's way more fun to
be ridiculous in this script that makes
slightly more sense when you find out it
was written for Schwarzenegger and
Stallone oh man that would have been
awesome but at least we got escape plan
I never saw this JT how's this game plan
to pause today that it's one of those
like insanely so bad it's good things
that could have been it could have been
that but it's just like fine alright
yeah you want to watch them together so
you play along and there's a few fun
sequences but I'll pick something else a
time and dumber
I do like prison break movies yeah weird
and you've got a mini one and face-off
yeah all right thank you face on if you
love action director John Woo has
something for you as women addressed
John with his signature deeds their
dives to old Wiegel dig
and does so also someone necessary
Pollock as you enjoy action set-pieces
that never stop until they stop to point
their guns at each other dramatically
[Music]
cute is I don't care if I live hope they
shot them which hand I'm shoot that
hurts
now shoot shoot and shoot shoot damn it
shoot each other in your faces
over-the-top craziness of two actors
playing other actors pretending to be
themselves I think where Nick Cage acts
like John Travolta learning to act like
Nic Cage while John Travolta acts like
Nic Cage slowly realizing how boring it
is to be John Travolta
don't worry weird so is everyone else
this movie is like the script that NIC
cages character and adaptations the cop
who's hunting himself he doesn't realize
he's hunting like a three serial killers
and they're all this they're all they're
all split personalities and there's this
big chase at the end it's symbolic of
the chase between man and horse what
actually is what inspired me to want to
be a movie critic Wow because I was in
college and that movie came out and the
critic for the school paper missed the
point of the movie completely like they
gave it like a C and they're just like
it was a good movie to the last third
and then it got really ridiculous I'm
like that's the voice inside like that
day I'm like I want to write for you and
they're like it was like God need to say
like no you [ __ ] like boy
but yeah you're right like that is
definitely Donald Kaufmann special just
like nauseating they're both each other
I'm so glad that article came out
pre-internet otherwise you just would
have left a hateful youtube comment and
left it that left a hateful youtube
comment but you would have begged then
maybe yeah yeah I don't know back 1
reviews used to be written paper like
read a review from yeah you tell what
that aggregate aggregate score it was a
simpler time the Philadelphia Inquirer
yeah anyway let's keep on yeah sorry
site wreck that's Archer love body swap
comedies like Freaky Friday but wish
everyone was trying to kill each other
then faceoff is the only movie crazy
enough from 96 to 97 for you
except maybe Conair or The Rock wow what
a crazy couple of years for action
movies huh and by action movies I mean
the cage castles look who's stalking
despite all my rage I am still just
Nicolas Cage emo Philips I used to love
doggie chow The Bourne Supremacy
Margaret Cho that's weird the director
of the notebook that's even weirder can
look at what you say about John
Travolta's your little peepee right
remember me I'm your favorite piece
peaches Travolta's weird face touching
habit
think that was even in the strip we can
be talented
idina menzel trading faces you know
we've been living together as man and
wife for a week how does she not know it
was her husband's face on a new body did
they switch dongs too because Dolloff is
a very different movement a while since
they slept together because he weirdly
kept it in her journal like it's been
two months since we made love which yeah
but they've been married for a long time
I mean you would think she makes she
would know and think yeah unless that
was I mean we think we talked about this
on movie fight oh wait would she know
who would ever think that their husband
has swathes life is another person if
it's dark yeah I mean unless it's
abnormally different right dawn off is a
different movie yeah I just think that
yeah I don't know I mean I've obviously
not been in a decades-long marriage ever
but do you think that he would know
enough about your partner that if it was
literally a completely different person
that you'd be like wait a minute
something's not right
yeah well me not only just didn't buy
Dongs but just the way that be a tip-off
guys a little confused know like these
pheromones there's so many things that's
like literally like yeah I just terribly
yeah just I've always wondered like is
this or Team America got Val more fun
icing from this like what kind of found
whorfin isin it's just like gluing yeah
guys do you think you would recognize a
stranger's dog on your loved ones body
that it's not in the comment yeah we
want to know when we get your test
someone put the time code of where this
question is don't question at 12:53 the
video starts at this moment
no carnies where cakes your lucuma sorry
Wow
and comment police team Demerol come in
please it's like we're commenting on the
trailer before the trailer starts that's
what the show is slight um I did have it
yeah no that's it I'm keeping that one
in for a while
we did one with the Lion King yesterday
it's like video starts at 2 minutes and
15 seconds you don't have 2 minutes and
15 seconds to let us ramp up a little
bit to talk to the director my Lion King
arm up get him warmed up David Letterman
doesn't David Letterman that's my age
Jimmy Kimmel doesn't go hey do you know
whatever yeah anyway do you have any
sense of foreplay enjoy faster damn it
right in there did you fast forward to
the game of Thrones opening when you
were watching it yeah that one I mean if
I'm binging maybe maybe you guys
wouldn't recognize the dong or the
different lovemaking styles if you're
just for playlists yeah you just dive
right in yeah they'll definitely notice
if someone's like just watching the
whole video if you know what I mean
that's why you ramped up yeah who do you
think should be in face off - what time
coach
I suggest like 11:32 felt pretty good to
me so yeah great if you called them what
the start of the bag I think the whole
thing is cringy interrupting our therapy
session CFL video starts now
so if you love body swap comedies like
Freaky Friday but wish everyone was
trying to kill each other roast each
other this ridiculous chance as well
wouldn't work each other's family
members yeah
starring Johnny Cage greased fight named
Nick Travolta stretch rage in caged in
guy in Jurassic Park 3 showgirl violence
against mirrors
[Music]
you see
they don't like their face oh man uh-oh
that bomb is gonna go off in 11 days
boss so stupid too long a countdown why
would you set a countdown I mean three
days sure that's a program one that
that's that long yeah it's just sitting
there in the convention center to just
like hope nobody finds it for 11 days
maybe like 24 hours give you time to
leave Los Angeles mm-hmm but 11 days the
only reason to set it for that long is
to give it just enough time for you to
get knocked unconscious switch faces
come out just to make it plausible be
like [ __ ] this balloon would take 4 to
get his face off and switch right
exactly very being very generous too
it's also not hidden at all no it's
hidden in like a doorjamb please put it
behind the mop thing in the janitor's
closet like I mean it's kind of bare and
I love that it was set during like some
kind of Catholicism convention in Los
Angeles just to make a dress Nick Cage
like a priest not like le Pope fish food
trucks yeah Pope comes the popemobile
food trucks yeah so good yeah no I was
telling Joey I think you spent
suggestions like I always forget how
inconsequential that bomb is to the plot
of the movie rights like I you think
going in like oh that's gonna be the
climax is like they're gonna be racing
to either it's to set the bomb off and
it's literally just John Travolta like
yeah the bump gets diffused really quick
and that's like his jump from like I
have to find this bomb to I have to swap
faces it's very quick like a bomb sweep
of Los Angeles there were like evacuate
the city he's like I know what I'll do
switch faces and then go talk to his
brother in jail yeah there are only so
many places in Los Angeles that it makes
sense to set a bomb we could activate
one of the largest law enforcement
communities along with the FBI and our
intelligence for anything out of place
in any of our landmarks or and stay with
me we could put your enemy's face on
yours
nobody tell and not do the tell anybody
and now and you to a top secret prison
where you can extract the information
from his brother yes now let me play
devil's lair a little bit because the
organization that he works with is so
secret that when they make an order
nothing happens they does a weird level
of complication to like remove them from
law enforcement in the FBI yeah he's
like my units so secret like we clap our
hands and no one even knows what to do
like they're so secret and then they do
this other weird layer of abstraction
because castor Troy himself isn't a
terrorist he's a terrorist contractor so
that bomb was for somebody else who they
did not try to round up or interrogate
or anything like that
he's like a terrorist consultant for
hire he's like Moriarty from Sherlock
just like the guy behind the guy behind
the guy well and they'd like there we
only told three people but like two of
them weren't doctors so did like the one
there's no there's no face sponge person
that had to like suction since I got
yeah it knows a one-man job there's no
nurse with the hose could bring up in
our trailers but we don't yeah we have a
lot to say on this one Wow the best
I wonder how their faces don't keep
falling off that surgery is still pretty
fresh and I think they come loose after
this or this or this
that'd be a great moment for this base
is just hanging above this one
scar doesn't heal that fast makeup no
when your Rickles in the makeup they
told you it's without all the cutting
and cutting edge technology juristic
surgery technology yes yeah no scars
yeah yeah
with 3d printing print the ear the knee
hurt yeah and the voice chip that they
put in that matched it perfectly based
on that one recorded line of dialogue we
found a vocal thing of him talking about
vaginas can you match it yeah long story
short I was like so easy we've been
recording him for days we've gathered
throwaway line another long story short
John we was very lucky that he made this
movie before the advent of Internet film
criticism because it's a whole other I
don't know I think it's extinct sin a
plane and away people have fun but even
snakes on a plane if you like the
build-up everyone was like oh yes more
silly when they made it that so sad that
words and stuff it was really well
reviewed at the time it came out like
masterful performance bad I don't think
they do great for Mance's are actually
spot on because they're having fun
against each other yeah yeah I still
like this man I do chance does it is
this was a great week at work like any
time when any time you walk into the
writer German one of us is watching face
off like that's a good week that's a
good week or yes what did you think of
face off and who would you want to see
in a sequel who's father face should
come off a third face tell us below and
tell us what time code we should start
at that's it for this week's election
commentary we'll see you next week for
the next one have a good one bye
thanks again to t-mobile for sponsoring
today's episode check out what makes
them America's best unlimited network at
t-mobile comm slash coverage
you